what do you think about women in the red
pill
I I uh because I was actually surprised
you you took this club I thought you
didn't collaborate with women I don't I
do collaborate with women oh okay but I
think that this space is Right meaning
the leaders should be male right the
leaders the overwhelming prevailing
thought should be males in our system
though
the women get a pass for saying this
stuff and I get punished you know what I
mean I tell you about my channel
Dynamics and I'm getting severely
punished for this whereas the women can
get to get this message out so what I
tell people is um there's a certain way
I collab and there's a certain way I I
Collapse so I'm very specific but
women are get been invited to this space
because it's a popular thing now right
do they know do they want to know the
truth or want to be popular that's what
I don't know so I say the prevailing
voices should be male right we should be
dictating what's going on what's said
and if there's a female in the space she
should be coming to the male voices she
should be going to the male voices and
saying what do you think about this what
do you think about that if they're
developing the philosophies around this
then it's going to fail
it's gonna fail for men
and I think what men have to understand
is they can't put hope in the female
content creators they have to put hope
in the male consecrators because we're
the ones that have the most at risk so
yeah I mean I think women are saying I
got red too
but tomorrow
no no how female nature works tomorrow
well I don't believe in none of that
stuff no more yeah I've seen that I'm
not happy I can't even fault you for
that like I've seen that have that
happen so when it's convenient yeah but
like I don't believe that no more [ __ ]
I've seen it happen so I can't even I
can't even follow I I haven't done that
myself
yet as we say when we talk about women
you use the words yet and right now at
any at the yeah well because we're we're
um
we're kind of like every day we feel
something different so yeah I I
understand it so yeah that's why I'm not
you shouldn't be offended but but the
thing is I think what tends to happen is
because you know there's monetization
there's attention more women are willing
to say hey I believe this but then but
then they get tired of it because
they're not truly invested there's no
loss so they'd be like I don't believe
that no more and then they go moving on
to makeup channels and [ __ ] so now what
that that all that work that she's did
now has turned here's the thing most men
that come to these videos and this isn't
a slight them in that watching this
they're not red pill
right they're not they're they're simps
or their blue pill trying to find some
truth or they're purple people
there's not that many dudes that be like
I'm red people right they're not Red
Bull and so if I'm on the show I know
I'm all handsome and all that they might
watch for about 10 minutes but then when
they see a woman
they're gonna sit in there and listen oh
my God look at you I wish my sister I I
need to find a woman just like you I got
right they just really purple people
they live in the Hope strategy
there ain't that many women that are
going to be hardcore red pill and stick
to it all their life
The Hope strategy is dudes really just
hoping they find the Unicorn right or
they hoping that that um they're gonna
find something that nobody else has been
able to be able to make happen right so
their their strategy which hope is not a
strategy but their strategy is to Simply
go I hope I find the best scenario
instead of working for it
or instead of like changing their
philosophy like okay I don't need that I
can find another life do you know that
most men
if you remove validation in women from
their life like women validating them
they wouldn't do a damn thing
anyone
let me sit right there [ __ ] on
themselves
they wouldn't even clean clean
themselves they wouldn't do nothing
they wouldn't do a damn thing they live
for women's validation like dudes would
go to uh what college you gonna go to
whoever the best women are at you know
what I'm saying like what is the Arizona
State that's like the hot girl I'm going
to hot girl Camp going to Arizona State
they got fine ass girls there or or
they'll be like um hey man hey we're
going to this party or are they gonna be
on any holes there you know what I mean
like that's the whole incentive they're
gonna go to the gym to make sure yoga
pants [ __ ] are there all right they
don't do nothing
yeah no I I did re I I used to uh
do kind of promotions for like a bar at
my college and that's how I'd Market it
like I would tell the girls that the top
guys were going and I would tell the
guys that the hottest girls were going
yes and neither told me they were going
you told the other groups yeah oh
they're gonna be some girls you know
it's gonna be 50 girls yeah that's their
first who's coming and so I I'd always
respond like oh and just mention like
the best like the most best looking like
yeah on campus exactly and then I would
mention like the hottest girls like so
they would just and then it'll work out
and then they show up all what are we
doing they had they added a sausage fish
all of a sudden and the girls didn't
show up yeah but you know this typically
a sausage fans yeah that's typically
what happens of ladies night right the
lady night promotion back in the 70s and
the 80s they basically were like women
in free it will give you two drinks that
way me ain't gonna go show up because
there's women there right if they don't
if they charge the women full entry fee
and they charge them for every drink and
then no dudes bought no drinks women
ain't going to that [ __ ] and then by
Versa men don't show up so when I say
dudes I'm not saying dudes are weak for
living for validation of women but I do
give men another life some other things
to aim for and that's the cheat code
that's the secret of life when you find
out and put women in their proper
perspective you get access to more women
can you explain that more most men so
let's go back to the girls that get that
that their their their boyfriends
cheated on them that don't leave this is
prime example
that guy he don't vow he's not validated
by those women
he's figured out he might be a football
player he might be a Chad he might be
self-absorbed he's into his life he got
Hobbies he go fishing he's involved in
his life
other his life matters more than these
hoes but
as a consequence he keep getting hoes
right because we don't want a guy that
makes us the center of his yeah yeah
what woman wants that you're my
everything he texting you every day
where you at pearly where are you why
are you here who's there you know what I
mean that's annoying right
but that guy keeps getting hoes
now these pickup coaches I hate them
they go around saying I you're validated
by women so they just want you to run
around and talk in 100 women and all
that [ __ ] I I think that's
ridiculous the the cheat code is get a
life
now guys that wish they were dudes like
that end up all day thinking about why
those guys keep getting the girls and
they never put two and two together
they'd be like because he's tall because
he's handsome yeah that has something to
do with it but it's the fact that he
doesn't put them first that guy puts
himself first and he keeps
I like selfish yeah but girls like it
yeah yeah
he put them he can tell them what it is
and she could go
I don't want that but most times she
goes
I have a question yeah all right a man
has two girls yeah he lies to one and
tells the truth to the other which one
does he love
he lies to one and tells the truth to
the other
damn
I think whoever he's lying to he
probably loves yeah yeah
I think that's a good question though
I've never thought about that one
but
yeah that's interesting I would say he
loves whoever he's lying to he loves
right
yeah and he doesn't want to hurt the one
emotionally he knows that if he if they
if he finds out the reality then he's
gonna lose him right so the one he likes
to okay
um as many of you know I was just banned
on Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible